belle tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi per la mia e per
la vostra gioia ma soprattutto per la
mia senza reti su già metri dai questo
che ho fatto che i storia passata già
stavo più facendo ragabo lo dico questo
ecco questo noi questo è già sta già
piangendo di suo non voglio piangere
meglio meglio così va bene cos'è sta
roba che cazzo è conclusa portale per
narnia ap la wilde da shingo ning tutto
ok ma devo saltare tipo fisico
addossando o premere anche quando salto
praticamente bellissimo ok ragazzi
niente volevo dire primo tentativo e lo
finisco ma mi sa proprio di non lo so
che ci posso fare
me lo sento dentro stavolta quella buona
adesso presso lo prendo tutto il mondo
praticamente mai così lo vinco subito
convinto proprio gasatissimo vai mio dio
ecco dio non mi devo muovere bene sono
perdo subito a caso ok per un fenomeno
ragazzi è un carmelo sto dicendo un
casino è ve lo dico già che chi è che ha
pagato cubi e li ha messi in mezzo
madonna mi sono salvato ok
dovevo stare calma perché so già che mi
sto citando e quindi perdo ok ok ragazzi
cibo donna ok lo so ho più sono salvati
una maniera incredibile mia gara
madonna non ci crede non ci sto credendo
non si possono se parli se parlo perde o
associate lo stare zitto lo stare zitto
ma non ce la faccio
ragazzi non ce la faccio madonna casa ma
io ci credo fermi un attimo mi sta
salendo l'adrenalina una maniera
incredibile mi sta salendo la telecamera
si sa chi è
ragazzi è stato come cazzo è possibile
che ci ha messo 101 tentativi per fare
sta merda e uno o due per farne per fare
questo è impossibile stato a sud layout
prof
ancora questo sei bellissimo
gianfrancesco te lo dico partiamo male
mi fece incazzare è assurdo ma la bene
conico mi succede quando me lo sento mi
succede che riesco non so perché lo
sentivo già dall'inizio anche in questo
non sto sentendo vai così las vegas di
tanto mi succede sta cosa che non lo so
mi sento che vinco e vinco a qualcosa
mimì su cielo spesso sta roba
manco per il caso mi succede mai però va
bene non importa che a voi fate finta
che sia vero perché potrebbe essere e
successi andata di culo con mio dio non
devo saltare [ __ ] e poi la gara
già mica io mi son dimenticato di tenere
non tenere in alto il mouse che sono
sembra che non gioco io non l'ho fatto
ragazzi ma [ __ ] [ __ ] fatto
finora ragazzi mar di abbado nella
vostra fiducia ho giocato io ma anche il
terzo no no si altro giocatore davvero
questo tragico ma poi ragazzi ma io mi
so se perché somatiche fast e musiche
che sono bellissime [ __ ] non me lo
devo neanche chiedermi hanno scritto in
molti ti può farvi fi geometri dash che
questa è la coppia di geometri dash
quando sotto il video di the impossible
game cazzata ragazze da impossibile che
mi è stato il primo a uscire così quindi
non di teste blasfemia che non è vero
ok ok ok ok prefetto basta casa
serio è una presa per il culo cosa dove
la mia adorata supposta bruttissima sta
frase perché mi si è girato il mondo
vabbè che hai bevuto zio si vede dalla
faccia proprio come se non fosse
difficile già già prima maledizione cioè
se fossi sullo smartphone girerei il
telefono però mica mi sa che girare il
monitor nomi conviene
ok ok ok no anche impossibile a meno che
non mi mette a testa in giù quando suola
fermi un attimo poiché ci arrivo mi
metto a te stesso ci provi sarà tragico
si trova lo stesso bravo ma [ __ ]
dal ragazzo sapevo che finiva cosi non
fate i commenti non mi guardate mariano
forse ce la posso fare
stavolta ce la faccio sono carico
scarico ok
vai forza si ok è impossibile perché non
capisco quando devo saltare con non devo
star fermo impossibile sul duro
madonna non ce n'è mai nella vita
propria come casa sta musica mio dio
sì no no no no no no no no no proprio no
proprio no eh no non so se ho già detto
non però no a pochi casi perché questo
impossibile
sì l'ho fatto ragazzi ci ho fatto mi che
non si capovolge una doppia dovessero
vincere per forza non ce la farò mai più
se perdo adesso basta non è possibile
i ragazzi dopo vinse di merda lassù poi
io pensavo si capovolgesse di nuovo è
invece c'era la supposta credetemi sto
gioco mi demolisce le capacità cerebrali
e già e già sono poker pro e 9 mentre
gara è assurdo non so perché mette
consigliato giovamento tra tutti i
giochi di merda che potevate di merda
sottolinea di merda che potate
consigliare perché geometri darsi
proprio negli merda nel senso che mi fa
incazzare nonché brutto forse anche
brutto però dipende tutto questo livello
la come o finisco mi sembra che sto
combattendo in arena ragazzi a baa1
[ __ ] eva scazzi ma il creatore
visto gioco quando non ho fatto ha detto
ma che bello chiedi impossibile game
perché non ne facciamo uno simile no
seriamente non voglio sapere i problemi
che affliggono queste persone voglio
conoscerle stringerle la mano ma forte è
la mano dove volevo da lì piangere mette
via stringo si si oh mio dio ragazze
carmine mi sto casandrino quando succede
così mi occorreva mille e perdo per
quello convinto proprio la supposta alle
sorelle è la supposta è la supplichiamo
uno sbaglio più su si
migliaia in cui i più grossi ma kakà
gara mangiato hamburger stavolta ok ok
se sì come dio mio dio mio limite
finisce così ti prego ti prego ti
supplico no un cazzo
maledizione qua visto svenendo oddio
oddio mica questo male io sto male sto
malissimo
sto male ingiusto ditemi che c'è un
rilevatore di battito cardiaco perché
non potete capire quanto sto correndo in
questo momento tantissimi cieli e tutto
quanto quanto sei bella io voglio la cui
la curiosità solo per vedere noi
veramente a parti scarsi solo mi
interessa neanche guardare grazie di
avermelo fatto grazie 1 per cento sono
soddisfatto dei ragazzi concluso qui
l'episodio perché piace tanto giocare
questi giochi però c'è da fare la
settimana enigmistica chiodo ragazzine
che posso concludere qui il video a dir
la verità o quando ho fatto questo video
stavo giocando ancora la demo di
geometri lascia adesso è uscito il gioco
completo quindi ragazzi nel prossimo
episodio vedo di fare anche più di due
livelli a episodio se volete che io lo
faccia il compito di facciamo in realtà
non l'ho letto che io faccia prossimo
episodio non lo sapete ancora ma poi non
lo volete i ragazzi 6 video vi è
piaciuto una società certamente mi piace
anche pace di facebook e come noi video
trovata restrizione sui siti specifici
vediamo al prossimo video belle ragazze